on april 16 1999 the raleigh ripper was
finally brought to justice after a reign
of terror across the state of north
carolina that left 14 women dead the
killer's true identity had been kevin
gruber a local gas station attendant
originally from west virginia who was
arrested at work in the early hours of
the morning his face was plastered all
over the media when he was cuffed and
dragged in to be questioned and
processed like many serial killers the
most frightening thing about kevin was
the fact that he just seems so
normal the idea that a person like this
could have committed the atrocities of
the raleigh ripper raised a frightening
question we all need to contend with
what turns a person into a monster this
question was particularly prescient for
dr james whittington a criminal
psychologist tasked with conducting the
first official psychological evaluation
on gruber ever since the true identity
of the killer had come to light the case
had held a particular fascination for
him mainly because gruber the man and
gruber the killer seemed to almost be
two entirely separate people according
to all evidence the raleigh ripper was
an insidious methodical criminal genius
he'd stalk some of his victims all women
who lived alone for weeks before
striking conducting detailed
surveillance of their homes that allowed
him to isolate them bypass their
security systems and remove any means of
getting help he blocked doors cut phone
lines and always selected vulnerable
targets despite being a seasoned
criminal psychologist the actual details
of gruber's crimes had kept whittington
awake at night he had a wife and a young
son at home and the thought of a man
like gruber prowling out there made him
fear for both of them this was no thrill
killer he was a sadistic torturer who
seemed to delight in the pain and terror
of his prey he'd chosen victims he could
take his time with infiltrated their
homes like a gust of cold air through an
open window and slipped out through
darkness like a shadow perfectly
controlled crime scenes no straight
evidence nothing but death left behind
for months he'd run circles around the
police thousands of people who fit the
raleigh ripper profile were interviewed
sting operations were conducted
communities formed neighborhood watches
to keep each other safe from the
killer's next move and none of it did
any good from seasoned detectives to
legions of beat cops nobody could get
the jump on kevin gruber the fact he was
even caught came out of pure chance a
local hiker mike fletcher just so
happened to hear the screaming coming
from a nearby home in the woods and made
the heroic decision to run in and
intervene when he walked in on gruber
committing the attack the killer
panicked and fled through an open window
in his haste he left a partial print on
the window frame that combined with
mike's description of the assailant was
enough to finally link kevin to the 14
murders of the raleigh ripper the
problem from dr whittington's
perspective was that by all accounts
kevin gruber seemed to be an idiot this
was no suave charismatic ted bundy type
in all the prior photos and interviews
kevin had that deer in the headlights
look of a man who's just in way over his
head dr whittington had also poured over
kevin's school records the only thing he
seemed to excel at was being mediocre he
even got held back a year in fifth grade
since graduating high school he'd been
kicked out by his parents for
freeloading and hadn't been able to
consistently hold down a job for more
than eight months his only prior
criminal convictions had been one drunk
and disorderly conduct charge and
possession of an ounce of pot back in
1991 for which he got a suspended
sentence due to being a minor at the
time it just didn't make sense to dr
whittington that this man and the
diabolically brilliant raleigh ripper
were the same person despite all the
incontrovertible evidence proving it so
despite his reservations he needed to
meet this man and find out why and how
he committed all these horrific murders
despite being such an unremarkable
individual sitting across from gruber in
the secure interview chamber whittington
was once again struck with how
incredibly disappointing he was thin and
wiry with glazed over eyes messy hair
and a pathetic tuft of weak stubble on
his chin he looked more like shaggy from
scooby-doo than a cold-blooded killer
his answers to most of dr whittington's
questions were also insubstantial with
him often losing his train of thought or
even needing to ask the psychologist to
carefully explain the question to him
most of the time gruber tried to make
irritating slow motion small talk
concerning everything from the weather
to movies he enjoyed the interview had
been utterly worthless until four hours
in gruber mentioned something that
awakened a strange memory in dr
whittington he said hey say doc you
remember that tv show bobble the clown i
love that show as a kid it was like my
religion you can't ever watch it there
were a number of unsettling things about
this from the fact that for some reason
dr whittington could remember something
about bobble the clown to the fact that
kevin gruber had no way of knowing that
dr whittington even had a kid but still
he didn't let his concern show and
instead asked gruber what he remembered
about bobble the clown gruber smiled and
replied all bobble taught me everything
i know doc to which dr whittington asked
the million dollar question like what
kevin gruber shrugged and just said all
kinds of stuff doc like how to watch
without being seen how did jimmy open a
window without making a sound how to
make him hurt real bad without him dying
see you can even make it last longer so
it can be more fun and of course he
taught me to get out without leaving
anything behind bobble made this all
possible doc and he told me all about
you too that all this was gonna happen
someday all good things have to come to
an end eventually right tell the wife
and kid he says hi by the way dr
whittington was astounded gruber seemed
to stare vacantly off into space for a
moment before suddenly claiming that he
had a terrible headache and he needed to
go back to his cell in any other
situation whittington might have just
written off bobble the clown as one of
two things a psychotic delusion or a
sophisticated psychopath faking a
psychotic delusion in hopes of getting
the insanity plea like the son of sam
killer david berkowitz pretending a
demonic talking dog possessed by satan
made him commit all of his murders but
whittington had heard of this bobble the
clown before and it wasn't in this
scenario that a gas station clerk like
kevin gruber ever would have heard of it
took half a day of research into his own
archived notes to remember exactly where
he'd heard it before a child he'd
interviewed almost a decade ago who
shoved gasoline and fireworks through
the letterbox of an old woman's home
leading to a fire that left the woman
and her dog dead when dr whittington
interviewed the crying child about his
motives he'd said that it wasn't his
fault bobble the clown had told them to
do it on the tv given that there were no
records of a bobble the clown show ever
airing on any local networks whittington
had written it off at the time as the
overactive imagination of a very
frightened very disturbed young child
that same child would later go into
psychiatric care before reoffending as a
serial arsonist upon release the last
building he ever burned down had only
one occupant himself
fire investigators would later state
that he had just sat there legs crossed
placidly waiting for the flames to lick
his bones clean it was becoming
incredibly clear that this bobble the
clown fantasy if it were even a fantasy
at all seemed to be much more than an
isolated phenomenon he used his
credentials to start exploring other
strange crimes of passion committed by
children and young adults even asking
some of his friends in the criminal
psychology community off the record if
they'd ever heard of such a concept
before frighteningly it didn't take dr
whittington very long at all to hit
paydirt there was the case of the arfio
family murders in 1985 out in arkansas
nine-year-old donnie orphio had taken
his dad's rifle out of the cabinet in
the dead of night and walked room to
room shooting his mother father and two
older sisters in their beds neighbors
had heard the gunshots and called the
police by the time they arrived at the
scene the only survivor was donnie
orphio himself drenched in blood sitting
in front of the tv his hollow eyes
stared zombie-like into the static he
did not resist arrest when donnie was
taken in for questioning his emotional
responses were cold and flat when he was
asked why he murdered his family he said
that it was because his father told him
he was watching too much tv his favorite
tv character bobble the clown had told
him that if he murdered his family with
daddy's gun he could watch as much tv as
he liked just reading this dr
whittington could feel sweat beating on
his brow two cases were a coincidence
but three were a pattern and oh how he
wish it had stopped at just three from
four days of searching he discovered no
fewer than 17 different seemingly
isolated crimes with mentions of bobble
the clown attached to the file a
five-year-old boy from new jersey who
drowned his neighbor's cat in a river
with a gym bag full of heavy stones told
police that he'd learned the technique
from bob of the clown an eight-year-old
girl arrested for tying up and torturing
her sister with a rusty coat hanger in
texas had of course gotten the idea from
watching an episode of bobble the clown
murder assault vandalism torture an
extensive country-wide rap sheet all led
back to that one recurring factor they
all learned it from watching bobble the
clown dr whittington had gotten in
contact with a few friends who knew
people in broadcasting while carefully
omitting some of the grizzlier details
he implored them for any new information
on whether a tv show with bobble the
clown had ever gone out anywhere but
despite their best efforts they didn't
find any records of bobble the clown or
any similar educational clown shows
airing was it possibly some complex
shared hallucination dr whittington
simultaneously felt burdened by all this
terrifying knowledge and utterly
powerless to do anything useful with it
if he started blowing the whistle to the
media or his superiors that a spat of
horrible crimes were all being caused by
a violent imaginary clown he'd just look
as deranged as any of the people he'd
been studying there seemed to be nothing
he could do to stop or help any of this
he returned home that night with a heavy
heart hanging up his coat he needed
someone to talk to about all this but he
couldn't burden his wife with the
horrors he encountered daily on the job
much less a living nightmare like this
mysterious bobble the clown as he walked
towards the kitchen to pour himself a
stiff drink he heard strange jaunty
music coming from the living room he
stepped back and saw his seven-year-old
son ben watching something on tv
as he stepped closer he could scarcely
believe his eyes
then entranced eyes fixed on a dancing
grinning animated clown on the screen
ben slowly turned his head towards dr
whittington eyes wide and bulging and
said i've been waiting for you to get
home daddy bobble said he got tired of
playing with kevin he wants to play with
us now dr whittington turned and looked
at the clown on the screen again he
could swear it was smiling right at him
that was the last thing he remembered
before the sudden intense headache and
the ground standing up to embrace him
when he woke up he was in bed with his
wife and neither of them could move
thanks to the heavy ropes binding their
body to the frame bobble is very good at
teaching children to tie knots they
tried to scream but a shiny flash of
duct tape held both of their mouths
closed dr whittington's eyes swiveled in
his head to ben standing at his bedside
the boy was holding a kitchen knife and
he was very eager to show his mom and
dad the fun new trick bobbled the clown
had taught him to the scp foundation
this terrifying anomalous tv show is
known as
scp-993 known to cause blackouts in
adults and violent anti-social behavior
in children they do their best to keep
the broadcasts contained but if ever a
child in your life seems to be acting
strangely perhaps ask yourself very
carefully what they're watching when
you're not around now go check out the
secret at the bottom of
scp-087 explained and procedure 110
montauk revealed fear alone
scp-231 tail for more harrowing tales of
anomalous terror